quick update to the story involving
president-elect Donald's phone call with
Argentinian President Mauricio Macri
there were allegations made that during
that phone call which was presumably
sort of like a diplomatic
congratulations for winning the election
type phone call with the president of my
home country of Argentina the allegation
was made by Argentinian journalist
coraje lanata that Trump wanted help
from makati to move a real estate
project forward this is a 35-story
office building in my birth city of
Buenos itís that was reportedly stalled
for years now right after the story
broke maconie spokesman Ivan pavlovsky
said now they didn't actually talk about
that during the phone call well if they
didn't talk about it there has just been
a huge coincidence because three days
after that call during which supposedly
there was no discussion of trumps
building project in Argentina the
Argentinian firm why why development
group announced that lo and behold the
project is finally going to start moving
forward after being held up for years
with the developers announcing that they
plan to start construction next year now
of course this is correlation it's not
causation but it really highlights that
Donald Trump must put his assets in a
blind trust he doesn't even know what
that is it can't be run by his kids he
has to disclose what the assets are do
what the other presidents have done I
mean George W Bush did the right thing
President Obama did the right thing with
regards to this and it's almost as if
Donald Trump is using his new position
to further his private economic gains
who could have predicted this sort of
top-level corruption corruption that we
call a kleptocracy oh everyone and how
are we going to explain this to people
in 30 years what will explain that you
know the people really wanted someone
who understood the common man and woman
to finally get into office and help them
and what better person did they find in
2016 then a billionaire from Manhattan
who used his presidential power to do
deals around the world and pad his
pockets it's going to be very difficult
to explain this to people in 30 years